[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المنتخب الفلسطيني راح يعني يعني يكون
لديه دعم كبير جدا هذه هي المشاركه
الثالثه لمنتخب فلسطين في نهايات كاس اسيا
الظهور الاول كان في 2015 في استراليا
الظهور الثاني كان في 2019 في الامارات
نتمنى الظهور هذه المره في المشاركه
الثالثه يكون نتائجه افضل ومعنويا ايضا
دعم للمنتخب الفلسطيني ولاخواننا في غزه
اعتقد ان الكل يتعاطف مع منتخب فلسطين في
هذه المشاركه خاصه وانه هذ المشاركه تاتي
في ظروف استثنائيه ومعروفه لدى الجميع
لذلك منتخب فلسطين سيجد دعم كبير جدا من
كل الجماهير العربيه المنتخب الفلسطيني
اكيد قبل ان يشارك فهو بالنسبه لي
وبالنسبه للكثيرين هو بطل هذه النسخه
الغير متوج حتى وان لم يصل لمنصه التتويج
فوجوده ومشاركته في ظل هذه الظروف الصعبه
التي كانت تحتم على اي فريق اخر لو غير
الفلسطينين انهم كانوا اعتذروا وانسحبوا
عن المشاركه لكن هذه هي الروح وهذه هي
الاراده وهذا هو الصمود الفلسطيني كما
اعتدنا فان شاء الله باذن الله نتمنى ان
يترجم هذا الامر وهذه الروح القتاليه
العاليه للاعبين داخل المستطيل الاخضر
بتاهل تاريخي باذن الله لاول مره في تاريخ
الكور الفلسطينيه وتخطي حاجز دور
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المجموعات